[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
it's increasingly common to receive
triple a experiences from free to play
games
fortnite warframe destiny 2 genting
impact
and apex legends to name a few now 2021
is here i thought we'd look through
10 free games coming to playstation and
other platforms over the next 12 months
as long as you keep in mind these games
will try to get your cash through micro
transactions you'll be fine
here's 10 free free-to-play games
dropping in 2021
and please let me know if you want
content around any of these games
let's do this let's start with the most
recent
announcement scavengers scavengers is
described as a strategic survival
battleground with heavy action shooter
elements
squads of three players must survive the
harsh weather using campfires to keep
warm
and hunting animals for food the action
is both pve
and pvp meaning there's a.i horde to
fight in addition to other real life
players
we choose from a roster of explorers who
possess unique weapons and abilities
and then we are thrown into this new
world tactical intelligence and straight
up gun play and melee fights
are the addictive parts here as you
attempt to dominate in this frozen world
by the way did anyone else here feel
cold when they play a game which has
snow and ice in it
okay just me moving on scavengers is
coming to ps4
xbox one and pc and recently there was a
closed beta indicating the game is
closer to fruition than we thought
with new game modes seasonal objectives
characters maps
enemies all regularly being updated and
changed scavengers looks like a great
free-to-play game with a huge amount of
potential
the pve vp element in which we fight
mutant ai controlled natives
and other players is the bit that sounds
most interesting if i'm honest
i'll keep you updated on scavengers
next we have roller champions a sports
game which is free to play
but this spot is not what you may be
expecting
roller champions is a three on three
roller derby
cross basketball hybrid we first got to
see this in 2019 but then the devs went
away
and will be re-revealing roller
champions in early 2021
in the game two teams compete to grab
five points by throwing a ball into a
goal
here's the interesting part by holding
onto the ball and completing laps the
ball becomes worth more points when
scored
but this also gives the opposition
chance to intercept
good old risk reward in action and just
like roller derby you can nudge
knock and tackle the opposition so this
could be a game to get your anger out in
at present
roller champions is coming to ps4 xbox
one pc
and nintendo's which gets in on the act
2.
next up we have fantasy star online 2
new genesis
coming in 2021 and this one's a little
confusing as it isn't fantasy star
online two
a quick history lesson fantasy star
online two is a huge rpg which has been
around since about 2012.
so almost nine years now over those
years we've seen vita versions we've
seen ps4 versions but only in japan
switch had an iteration and a few months
ago eu players on xbox had the chance to
play
let's clarify this fantasy star 2 online
is a little messy
so this is why we're getting a new
genesis version which will be released
separately for all players on pc xbox
switch and playstation the latest
trailer looks good enough to be a legit
sequel
and sega have stated this will be a
whole new universe
the combat looks much improved and
visually this is a beautiful looking
game
i haven't played fantasy star since the
sega dreamcast days so my knowledge base
is limited here but like usual
i'll keep researching and i'll let you
know more soon next up
league of legends wild rift you've heard
of league of legends right
you've likely seen the adverts and try
to understand what the heck is going on
in a match
yeah me too well 2021 will see the game
redeveloped for a console audience two
teams of five players do battle and
attempt to take down the opposition base
all across a map full of monsters and
runs
we get to choose our own champion who
has their own weapons and abilities and
their own unique designs this is where
skins come into play
tanks healers archers mages every class
you can dream up is likely in this game
as league of legends is made for a mouse
and keyboard the console version will
see mild overhauls to allow for
controllers and virtual thumbsticks
personally one of the reasons i never
gave league of legends a chance
is due to the typical battles lasting
around 40 minutes
riot has noticed this and found a way to
reduce this to around 20 minutes
which should better suit the player base
does this float you bow if so
be sure to check back with me in 2021
let's stick with strange japanese
cultural things i don't understand
next we have the first game with a solid
release date of march 24th 2021
and it's also the game with the most
ridiculous name you can imagine
please welcome love live school idol
festival
after school activity wayway home
meeting
yep that's that's really the name and
it's made by square enix no less
a rhythm game with a way bigger fan base
than i expected it's basically teenage
girls singing and dancing
um i'm not judging you if this is your
thing you do you
additional songs and costumes will be
the micro transactions here
i'm gonna go before the fbi bust down my
door
[Music]
the next game on the list is an online
rpg magic
legends coming to ps4 xbox one and
pc it's the stereotypical fantasy
role-playing game with a darkness
engulfing the world
and only you and your crew can save the
realm
there are five classes to utilize
ranging from the geomancer who draws
upon the power of the earth to pummel
enemies with stone and lava attacks
the mind mage utilizes psychic powers
beast caller
is what your mom calls me no i'm sorry
i'm sorry beast caller has a huge
spiritual axe and a fox companion
the sanctifier uses bots of light as
weaponry
and finally the necromancer raises the
dead horde to battle on his behalf
magic legend has certainly come a long
way since its reveal just under a year
ago
and is shaping up to be a solid fantasy
mmo rpg
what do you get if you cross battle
royale with world of warships
most likely re-fight the last warship
that's right
a boat-based behalf 30 players helm
ships ranging from destroyers to
cruisers
and fight to sink each other's
battleships with realistic physics and
designs from real-world ships
re-fight the last warship is trying to
grab the attention of arguably the best
warship sim world of warships and throws
the br into the mix to find something
new
in this gaming space refight will be
updated regularly like you'd expect with
new game modes ships and other options
right now it's available on steam and on
ps4 in asia
but in 2021 the game is coming to the
west so let me know if this one
floats your boat hey puns
[Music]
next we have knives out yet another
battle royale which has been around for
quite a few years
unlike other games on this list 2021 is
the year it comes to console
i'll be using footage from the current
pc and mobile builds to showcase this
game
and as you can see it sure is another
battle royale
knives out is massive in asia with
hundreds of thousands of people watching
pro live streams
there's not much i can really say it's
just another battle royale which wants
to succeed in the west
good luck knives out does anyone play
this on mobile already
throw an opinion below is this something
we should be hyped for
and finally caliber get your eyes around
this
a special forces focused tactical
shooter from the team which brought us
world of tanks and world of warships
caliber is a third-person team-based
tactical action game
which is currently enclosed beta on pc
and to be honest is many months away
from going multi-platform
but i wanted something with genuine
potential to be my final pick on this
list
playing as different classes we have
medic support assault and recon classes
and we fine-tune our team to take on
real-life opponents
the feel is much like cs go but with a
third-person perspective
and has some of the unique abilities
found in games like valorant
but in a way more realistic way over
time the game will evolve
and include military forces from all
around the globe kinda like how rainbow
six siege does this
i have high hopes for this game and
we'll keep you updated throughout 2021
it's been 10 months since the beta began
and thus more info should be
coming very soon hopefully let's hope
this is a high caliber game
more puns so there we have it 10 free to
play games coming through 2021
do any take your fancy i'm looking
forward to scavengers caliber
and maybe even trying roller champions
too i'll be in the comments looking to
see if you want me to make content about
any of these games
thank you for your time much appreciated
i'm adam from playstation grenade
see ya
[Music]